the remains of the bullet that killed
journalist shireen abu aklee this image
is being broadcast for the first time
and shows the type of ammunition used to
kill the veteran al-jazeera journalist
in the occupied west bank last month
according to experts the green tip
bullet is capable of piercing armor and
is used in a m4 rifle when we simulated
the green tip bullet using 3d models and
according to ballistic and forensic
experts the munition that ended shirin's
life was a 5.56 millimeter caliber
the bullet was first designed and
manufactured in the united states
according to the palestinian
prosecutor's office and the autopsy
report the bullet entered the lower part
of shireen's head ricocheted off her
helmet and lodged itself in her head
this m4
and this
munition is used by the
israeli army
and you just go through google you'll
find one of the uh guns which used by
the israeli israeli
army sm4
called m4 it's available and it is used
it is used by the
units
general fires also believes when using
such a bullet the intention is clear
when any soldier used it he used it for
for definite target
he want to hunt one tickle
we have used 3d models to identify the
types of weapons israeli soldiers were
using in this video
we found it was a m4 rifle the type of
gun that uses 5.56 caliber bullets
open source data supports the fact the
israeli special unit accused of shooting
shireen uses this type of weapon
used in a non-combat situation
fired by the israeli army at clearly
identifiable journalists doing her job
justice for shireen is yet to be
delivered accountability has still not
taken place
questions remain unanswered including if
an order was given to kill her why was
she shot despite being clearly marked as
a journalist and posed no threat
what made an israeli soldier target her
from such a short range all of this is
further reason why the palestinian
authority and al jazeera media network
have demanded an independent
investigation into the killing of
shireen abu aklee assad beg al-jazeera
all right joining us now from tel aviv
is origivati he's the advocacy director
at breaking the silence that's a group
of former
soldiers who've served in the israeli
military that want to speak out about
the reality of
what they see is the uh the israeli
actions in the occupied territories
thank you for joining us just explain to
viewers so they have an idea of who you
are what your background is i understand
of course you were not directly involved
in the events of that day
and you know obviously the killing of
shurina barclays but i want to ask you
in general through your experience
you've been a soldier you've been a
military man is this type of bullet the
5.56 is that something commonly used by
israeli forces
yeah look sami first of all uh thank you
for having me and i really recommend
uh al jazeera and everyone else who
continue to dive deep into this incident
it is so important for anyone who wants
to keep human rights and protect
palestinian rights
um
yeah for your question look yes this
bullet is a very very common bullet yeah
it's like the bullet that most soldiers
use during the service
um
but if i may i i may look at the broader
picture right
i think that the
the this investigation is extremely
important as i said
but we also have to remember that these
kind of incidents happen on a weekly
basis right it's important for you to
mention the
kid zaid decided only two weeks ago 14
year old was also killed and there is
less
talking about that is right and i think
we we should look into the killing of
shiri in a hundred percent but also
remember that killing innocent
palestinians is something that happens
on a weekly basis and most of them go
unnoticed
okay i'm going to get to that but if you
bear with me
for a for a moment before we broaden it
out i want to ask you a few more
questions about this bullet this is an
armor-piercing bullet right
what typically would you
not you personally what typically would
an israeli soldier use an armor-piercing
bullet for
when
i guess the people wearing armor body
armor
in the occupied territories israeli
forces and
journalists right
those are the people who typically wear
body armor
as i told also the producers we are not
experts in exactly what this specific
food be so i don't feel comfortable
answering that specific question because
it's not our area of expertise sure sure
i don't want to put you in in a
situation we have to speculate
debbie can tell us you would you were
talking
generally there about the targeting of
civilian palestinians
tell us about
instances
you know people listening to this
interview is this something that your
group has documented and seen and
experienced
how routine is that what kind of
instructions are issued to soldiers
in terms of how careful they should be
to avoid
civilian casualties when they are
operating in the occupied territories
look i think that we we have to remember
that there is a really big difference
between the orders that we receive as
soldiers and what eventually happens on
the ground which is what matters as a
soldier and we and all of our testifiers
receive a very clear and
you know rules of engagement
who will allow to open fire at what are
the right justifications for that and so
forth
but eventually when we see the missions
taking place yeah when we rule over
millions of people with the military
when we daily invade palestinian cities
and towns and homes
these orders
in many many cases are not even closely
fulfilled
and
i
the thing that we have to remember here
to look at here
is that
when
a
innocent palestinians are killed the
system always justifies it always
justified there is no accountability in
the military for a killing of innocent
people and this is why
the difference between the orders given
which if you know if i will now describe
to all the orders it will sound too
reasonable i believe
the problem is not that the problem is
the fact that we are
sending soldiers for 55 years to invade
in
places full of civilian people so of
course civilians will be killed
have you seen a pattern of that
happening you know your group have you
documented it a pattern
of the rules
protecting civilian life being ignored
systematically
in in the occupied territories
100 we have a
testimonies from hundreds of soldiers we
have the incidents that are happening
right let's take the killings of defense
on the gaza fence in in in march may
2018 right 63 people in one day on our
yeah we have killings of children in
non-violent protest we have dozens of
testimonies about how the orders are one
thing and what happens on the ground is
a completely different thing and in the
end the system doesn't really take care
or tries to improve because you know why
something because there isn't any way
to occupy millions of people into
military force and invade their homes
and villages and towns without killing
innocent people and the sad fact is that
the system as a whole doesn't really
care about palestinian lives okay i i
want to pick you up on something which
is very interesting you mentioned you
said we've got the testimony of a
hundred soldiers who say that
what happens
to
to those guys basically
that what happens in their testimony
after there has been
you know a deliberate violation of rules
that led to the loss of civilian life
take us through the process is there any
investigation does anybody question you
does anybody say you know how did that
happen how did you kill as you said
there's eight zaharani what or is it
just
everybody knows and keeps sight what
actually happens as a matter of process
yeah look uh just to work we have over 1
300 testifiers we have
thousands of testimonies from different
incidents all around
the occupied territories
and look
eventually the soldiers that we speak to
that give their testimony you know some
of them
the vast majority of them were part of
the missions
and some of them were the actual
enacters of the different
you know human rights violations
but in the end
and and this goes back to the
investigation of shirin also
the system understands yeah the
occupation the military israel our
country understands that if we will
really look into all these cases it will
all go back to the root cause
right
and this is why the system is terrified
from actually conducting investigations
right the soldier that is 19 20 21 years
old and receives a mission to enter the
city of janine yeah
uh with his unit
and he's faced with violence it's faced
with violence right important to
mention and ends up killing an innocent
palestinian
the vast majority of these cases will be
because the system sent him to do that
not because he so you're saying nobody
investigates them basically nobody
questions them when they come back
nobody investigates that
yeah of course you know like i haven't
seen israel investigate any
really you know for really investigating
any incident when we see investigations
of similar cases right it will only be
only be if there is a very clear
documentation of the incident yeah very
clear undisputable recommendation of the
incident and even then there will be no
accountability there might be some
disciplinary punishment you know we saw
a few years ago
a soldier
a killing it was very famous video in
the center of hebron a palestinian who
was lying on the ground after after
stabbing another soldier and he shot him
in the head clear video of healing of
someone who is not a threat at all
and this soldier received eight months
in military prison yeah so imagine what
happens to all the soldiers to all to
all the different in all the different
incidents of killings of palace of
innocent palestinians that are not
documented
we israel very clearly understands that
we cannot
investigate because every investigation
will end up
with the real blame and the real blame
is the fact that we decided as people to
occupy the palestinians and of course
innocent people will keep uh dying as
long as we as we do that as long as we
invade
their homes
okay thank you very much for talking to
us origivati there very important to
shed light on an issue which is
important for the human rights of
palestinians as well as israelis to live
in in peace and respect thank you so
much
thank you very much